i know it's early but i have got a shot
and a chaser for you here's the shot
you'd often get asked look the
republicans don't play it square why do
you play square yeah well well guess
what if we do the same thing they do our
democracy will literally be in jeopardy
well i mean i'm not a joke
and i i understand that argument but
also it's like you're playing monopoly
with somebody who you know won't pass go
and won't follow any of the rules and
how do you ever make any progress if
they're not
following the rules
you know
and there's that little box directly to
jail
directly
that's the president of the united
states saying on national television
that the only way to deal with
republicans is to throw them in jail
that's the shot here's the chaser
yesterday the fbi arrested a republican
candidate for governor in michigan over
misdemeanors that he allegedly committed
on
january 6th of last year
a serious rival to the incumbent
governor was arrested during an election
year over relatively minor crimes that
he may or may not have committed more
than a year ago
for some reason the fbi did not see fit
to arrest this guy for well over a year
after the alleged incident took place
but then the very week that democrats
are staging their january 6th show trial
in circus
the fbi decides to arrest a prominent
republican office seeker for
misdemeanors related to the topic of the
hearings
what are the odds boy oh boy what a
coincidence with each passing day
our country seems more and more to
resemble a banana republic
and for some strange reason it's
precisely the people who constantly
preen about our sacred democracy who
seem to be leading us faster and faster
toward it i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from phil veda who
says what's the big deal brett kavanaugh
is safer today than he's been
historically
that's true you're right brett kavanaugh
is as safe as the economy is strong
right now that's uh that's that's true
and given how weak the economy is you're
gonna want to save money on your cell
phone plan that's why you gotta check
out puretalk right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code
knollspodcast
i absolutely love puretalk i love the
service i love my cool phone that i just
got i love how incredibly easy it was to
get my pure talk service and phone
verizon att t-mobile they are charging
you a premium fee every month for data
that you don't use stop paying for
things that you do not use instead of
paying 89
a month or more to your current provider
pay just twenty dollars to pure talk for
what you actually need
i have i was skeptical i was skeptical
i've i'm always skeptical of new cell
phone plans i know it's annoying to
switch and then i did it and it was
super easy they've got
absolutely the best service out there
you're not gonna you're not gonna lose
on service they got the best phones out
there you're not gonna lose on phones
the only thing you're going to lose is
the annoyance of paying way too much
money to those cell phone companies so
right now go to puretalk.com select a
plan then enter promo code knowles
podcast to save 50 off your first month
you can be switched over to puretalk in
less than 10 minutes i'm not joking
promo code noel's podcast canon wles
podcast all one word at puretalk.com
puretalk is simply smarter wireless
come on jack come on man well i play by
the rules man that's what i do
i don't that listen if i didn't play by
the rules unlike those pesky republicans
our democracy would fall apart that's
that's the first thing joe biden says in
the first half of his breath and then
what in the second half he says and
that's why i've got to jail my opponents
for opposing me
he used to be a little bit better with
the messaging joe biden he used to be a
little bit better with the bs and that
has gone out the window the appearance
on jimmy kimmel was absolutely
disastrous the the clip of it that's
going around right now that probably
went most viral was joe biden rambling
about
biracial television commercials
i'm serious you turn on the tv look at
the ads when's the last time you saw
biracial couples on tv when's the last
time you saw the way i mean people are
selling products they do ads to sell
products and they sell products when
people they appeal to people this
generation is going to change everything
we just got to make sure we don't give
up
when was the last time that you saw
biracial there are so many things wrong
with this joe biden has used this line a
lot but he got it backwards this time
the line that he usually uses to show
the progress that america has made is
that now you can't turn on a tv without
seeing an interracial couple which is
true there are a lot of
it is it is sort of odd actually that
interracial couples seem to be far more
represented on television than in the
united states at large but but that's
what he's pointing to except he got it
backwards and he can't keep his words
right anymore and he blames it on a
childhood stutter that he had when he
was eight that disappeared for 70 years
and then popped back up again so he got
it wrong and he said you don't see
biracial couples also he doesn't know
what the word biracial means biracial is
like halle berry
if we were talking about biracial
couples on tv we would say that everyone
on tv were halle berry hewed and they
were all there was were
slightly only slightly darker than i am
the word that he's looking for is
interracial so
the only reason i bring it up is not to
make any point about his stupid
observation on the tv it's to point out
even the lines that he is most practiced
with even the lines that he has used in
his stump speeches for years now even
those get jumbled up in his mushy
pudding head then
joe biden rambles so badly
that that jimmy kimmel actually has to
cut him off and go to commercial
but here's the deal
one of the things is that it's very
difficult now
to have a
even
with notable exceptions even though
really good reporters they have to get
number clicks on on on nightly news
so instead of asking a question
anyway it's just everything gets
gets sensationalized and weighs it but
i'm convinced we can get through this we
have to get through it and one of the
things look i'm going to take a break
and then we'll talk a little bit more if
you don't mind i'm sorry i'm sorry we
have some of those commercials we have
some biracial commercials we need to
show we'll be back with president
that was a pretty good save by jimmy
kimmel but it was so sad how he had to
lean into it because he leaned into it
the way that when when you've really got
to go to a meeting when you've really
got to get off the phone and you're
speaking with an elderly relative the
way hey hey before hold on before you
get into that story great great grandpa
we need i just we're gonna take a little
break okay and then and then he makes
the biracial joke which was which was
pretty funny but it's not funny enough
to save the interview what is biden
talking about you know back in my day
sunny we didn't have all these clicky
clicky doodads and websites we had the
pony express and that's what that's what
we did jack and we would go and you'd
have to you go to the gutenberg press if
you wanted your news stories
but then okay hey hold on
just one second there mr president we've
got to go cut to commercial to end this
misery
and then finally the the probably the
most important point worth mentioning in
this disastrous interview
was that joe biden is appearing on jimmy
kimmel
the night after
a leftist assassin showed up to brett
kavanaugh's house because he was upset
about the court potentially overruling
roe vs wade which he only found out
about because a leftist on the court
leaked it and he found brett kavanaugh's
address only because a leftist group
doxed kavanaugh and the night after that
happens
joe biden shows up to this national talk
show very few people watch it but still
a national show
and he says if the court overrules row
by golly you might get a revolution
it's clear that if in fact the decision
comes down the way it does and these
states impose the limitations they're
talking about it's going to cause a mini
revolution they're going to vote a lot
of these folks out of office
a mini revolution now biden is a shrewd
enough politician still that he know he
he teases that
but then he pulls it back and he says
they're by voting it's going to be a
revolution by voting
but but joe biden does know the context
here and the context actually does
matter here he's showing up hours after
a leftist assassin
tries to murder a sitting supreme court
justice over this issue specifically in
his home in his bed where the justice's
wife and daughters sleep
and then biden
instead of instead of going on the
kimmel show and condemning that
i don't think biden knows about very
much these days but they certainly told
him that someone tried to kill the
justice
instead of going on and saying listen we
need to cool down the rhetoric we need
to restore the soul of a nation we need
to not be killing federal officials
certainly not judges at least no instead
of that he says hey
hey you know that thing that the cabin
almost got murdered for yeah well
i sure hope kavanaugh changes his mind
you know because hey listen jack listen
corn pop if he doesn't we might get a
mini revolution you know what i'm saying
hey come on there come on man come on
man come on
speaking of revolution
joy behar over on the view
just epitomized so much of the utterly
ignorant
arrogant
views of her side especially when
they're talking about guns
she the left is trying to grab guns i
think they know it's basically a lost
cause but she thinks she's identified
the one
way in which republicans might turn
against the second amendment and that's
if those black people get guns
here's the thing once black people get
guns in this country the gun laws will
change trust me
that's what happened with the black
panthers
trust me okay republicans are far more
racist than they care about the second
amendment now
this is obviously a very stupid
statement from joy behar but it's
especially stupid because she's speaking
to a black woman here on the panel on
the view and just
moments earlier but maybe i don't know
two minutes earlier
the black woman on the panel blew up
joy's theory
all right i just say this real quick as
a gun owner there are people in this
country that genuinely own guns you
catch that
gadget hi i a black woman as a gun owner
and then she goes on and and talks about
how we don't need all of these guns and
she's trying to find this moderate
position on it but she just told joy
behar
yes i own a gun and then what does joy
behar do she says oh shut up black lady
hold on you're getting in the way of my
narrative no black people they don't
have guns and once and those republicans
hate black people shh i said stop
talking black lady i'm trying stop
telling me about your actual experience
i'm trying to express my views about
your experience and black people yeah i
know i know there's a statistic says one
in four black americans already own guns
yeah forget about that for a second i'm
trying to make a point about how racist
you republicans are
now
when you want to protect yourself not
just your physical self but your digital
life you've got to check out expressvpn
right now go to
expressvpn.com you especially should
okay
because i have a feeling that you maybe
you're looking at some things on the
internet
that won't people around you if they're
looking at what you're seeing on the
internet they might not be so happy okay
some of those websites where you open up
that incognito window and what do you go
to websites you're not supposed to like
dailywire.com you know what i'm talking
about if the ruling class finds out that
you're going to that website they're not
going to like it very much so don't
leave your data out there for everyone
to take from you when you connect to an
unencrypted network you're at a cafe a
hotel an airport your online data are
not secured any hacker on the same
network can gain access to and steal
your personal data expressvpn creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so that they
can't it would take a hacker with a
super computer over a billion years to
get past expressvpn's encryption it's
great works on your phone works on your
tablet works on your laptop even works
on your smart tv i have it on all the
devices that i use get an extra three
months of expressvpn at expressvpn.com
knowles that's expressvpn.com
knowles
speaking of the view there was another
radical just showed up to the view not
one of those ladies but the joe biden
education secretary the joe biden
education secretary shows up on the view
to address this question of how to
protect schools one of the whatever you
think about gun control whatever you
think about ar-15s whatever you think
about whatever we should all be able to
agree that if you want to protect
schools there are some basic measures
that will help
lock the doors i think is locking the
doors ideological is that is that a
partisan battle now just lock most of
the doors have an armed guard there
is that having an armed guard to stop
the bad guys the i guess the cops are
ideological now
i guess they are partisan now really
shouldn't be
maybe let teachers who are law abiding
gun owners maybe let them carry their
guns you notice that the shooters always
attack
gun-free zones they always attack soft
targets so maybe
harden up those targets a little bit you
won't get as much shooting one of the
ladies on the view asks joe biden's
education secretary about this thought
and
he doesn't like it
some republicans have proposed arming
teachers to stop these shootings my
mother is a teacher
in ohio the governor is preparing to
sign a bill that would lower the
training requirements for a teacher to
carry a gun in the classroom from 700
hours to 24 hours
in your view do you support teachers
carrying guns in the classroom
those are some of the
stupidest proposals i've heard
in all my time as an educator so that's
my answer to that listen we need to make
sure we're doing
sensible legislation making sure our
schoolhouses are safe as much as
possible but to say that we're going to
arm teachers to protect students what
happens when a teacher goes out on
maternity leave are we going to give the
substitute of the day a gun
what this shows sonny is that some
people are clueless when it comes to
what's happening in our schools
some people are in fact clueless that's
true i i think dr miguel cardona here
the secretary groomer of education
wearing his little progress pride pin on
his lapel i think he might be the
clueless one
because he doesn't even understand
the
the argument for arming teachers he
proved that at the end he said at the
top
this is a dumb idea it's the stupidest
idea i ever heard doesn't quite explain
why and then he a little bit later he
gets to he says what what happens when
you have a substitute teacher you're
gonna give him a gun that's
the argument for arming teachers is not
that you require every teacher to have a
gun
the argument for arming teachers is that
you have
some teachers with guns
and and by the way you don't know
necessarily which teachers have the guns
and so when an assailant or a would-be
assailant comes into the school
pretty much everyone he sees potentially
could be armed and when that's the case
people tend to be a little bit more
polite people tend to be a little more
cautious and reticent
if they go into a school and they know
for a fact no one is armed then they can
run them up they can do whatever they
want
but you don't the point is not to have
every single person they're packing you
know arm the third graders too the point
is to just have some guns out there and
you don't know who's got them and you
could turn the corner to wreak havoc and
then boom there's the gym coach boom
there's the history teacher and you just
you just
don't know that's what joy behar was
proving up there when she made her
stupid point about about black gun
ownership all she's showing is that she
truly has no idea
what how one what black people think
about guns and two what conservatives
think
she thinks that if conservatives knew
that black people were getting legal
guns that they would turn on the second
amendment
many of you listening right now are
conservatives many of you listening
right now are black too is that
is that how you feel no of course not
but i give her
points for sincerity i think she
probably sincerely believes that and
she's just completely mistaken
dr groomer here secretary groomer
probably sincerely believes that the
arguments that conservatives are
advancing are
are for arming all of the teachers
because he's got wind blowing in between
his ears and can't process what we're
actually saying he probably just doesn't
know and he can chalk that up to
ignorance and a lack of curiosity but
that is not the argument that we are
making yet again we see
something that social scientists have
shown again and again over the years
which is that conservatives understand
the libs
much much better than the libs
understand conservatives
by the way the the argument for arming
schools for putting guards at least at
schools was just proven correct
yesterday
there was a man outside of an alabama
elementary school who was
demonstrating aggressive behavior
he was walking around he was yelling he
was trying to get into the school it was
unclear what was going on and a squ this
is just being reported by al.com a
school resource officer on site
responded talked with the man and called
for backup
then a second officer arrived an
altercation ensued and the suspect was
killed he was fatally shot
officials have not yet said if the man
was armed
doesn't necessarily matter if the man
was armed if the man was suggesting that
he might be armed
he's trying to break into an elementary
school he's demonstrating very
aggressive behavior
two weeks after a mass killing at an
elementary school
this is what's going to happen
who knows what would have happened
had that guard not been there
had there not been good guys with guns
on the site
one officer suffered minor injuries he
was taken to the hospital no kids were
harmed the kids may not not even have
known what was going on outside
but that's the stupidest idea i've ever
heard what you want you want to have
people with guns to protect people from
bad people with guns that was stupid how
stupid
how out of touch do you have to be
with not not just modern society but
with the basics of human nature and
self-defense
and incentives to make that kind of a
comment
speaking of
dangers that students face
i get tips sometimes and i encourage you
to send me tips to you can do it through
my personal website michael janels.com i
get tips of bad stuff that's going on in
local communities that maybe is not
getting national attention but it's
happening and that's we live our lives
in local communities we all pay
attention to the national news but much
of the stuff that affects our real
day-to-day lives and affects our kids
and the way that we raise our kids and
our whole families takes place at the
local level and
it's not just new york and san francisco
in chicago and l.a that have gone
bonkers it's places right there in the
middle of the country right there in the
heartland that are pushing some of this
radicalism on june 27th
i don't know what you're doing you
probably want to clear your calendars
because the davenport public library in
iowa in iowa of all places is hosting a
teen summer brunch
called drag queens and kings wake up
let's do brunch campy style okay so this
is for teens i already think that is
depraved and should not be legal and
should not be tolerated in a civilized
society
but then they say what are the ages that
can come to this
11 through 19.
it says teens ages 11 through 19 can
celebrate pride month by going to this
drag brunch
when did 11 year olds become teenagers
they're saying teenagers here because it
seems marginally better than saying hey
little kids come and let us let perverts
jiggle for you dressed up in stiletto
heels and maybe you can join in too
it'll be kind of fun won't it
they know that so they say teens you
know 11 like an 11 year old what do you
mean in 11 years yeah i'm just talking
you know teenagers like you know a 16
year old or a nine-year-old or a
four-year-old hold on that's not a t
that's not what a teenager is it's very
easy to figure out what a teenager is
the word teen is right at the end of the
age
13 14 15.
they can celebrate pride month
and the art of being theatrical extra
and campy after performances from a
local drag queen and drag king
miss amber will give book talks while
everyone enjoys donuts and other yummy
snacks registration is required
make sure you head on over there this is
going to be a wonderful wonderful event
do you want that in your communities in
iowa do you want that at the davenport
public library money is coming out of
if you're in iowa money is coming out of
your taxpayer dollars to go and fund
this sort of thing do you want to do
that if not i would call your
representative i would call up that
davenport public library and put a stop
to it it's not just in davenport
if you happen to be in moline illinois
and you happen to be there on june 18th
and you happen to have kids that you
want to pervert and disorder
you can bring them to the youth drag
workshop and show boy oh boy isn't that
going to be fun it's going to be held at
the stoney creek hotel in moline
and you can go and teach your kids how
to do drag
this will be this is a project of clock
incorporated
it's going to be a lot of fun do you
like brunch and activities then you
might be
interested in that as well it's gonna be
so so fun so you go you show up to the
workshop you have a great time and you
have little kids dance around it's not
just it's not even just a performance
it's a workshop you're teaching
little kids these youths
how to do drag learn from experienced
drag performers in a relaxed fun and
non-judgmental environment
i'm judging
i i don't know about you i'm judging i
judge that this is wrong and should be
illegal and the people putting this on
are perverts and the parents who are
taking their kids to it are abusing them
maybe wittingly maybe unwittingly either
way it's got to stop if you don't like
this call your representatives moline
illinois
taking place at the stoney creek hotel
say you don't want this here whenever
conservatives put on perfectly ordinary
events where we say basic truths about
our country or we have the audacity to i
don't know defend george washington or
something the lib activists call up and
try to get the conferences shut down by
calling the hotels by calling their
representatives here you've got a bunch
of pervs grooming little kids into weird
sex stuff surely we can call and say you
know hotel you're not getting my
business anymore if you keep hosting
this stuff you know congressman you know
state senator
i'm not going to vote for you if you
don't put a stop to this put a step we
have the right to say no to this creepy
stuff
the libs are obsessed with
transgenderism it's just as simple as
that there's this yale professor jason
stanley he's a yale professor of
philosophy i i truly
i have a lot of trouble believing that
this guy is earnest i wonder if he's
just a secret conservative troll who's
putting on a grand piece of performance
art he he writes about fascism coming to
america and how
you know evil the kind of modern
conservatives are and the grave threats
and
he takes himself so so seriously well he
just tweeted out quote
i haven't been focused as much as i
should have been
on supporting trans rights in the last
12 months i now realize that this is
where the fight for global democracy is
there is no avoiding it now if you just
read that statement
without any context at all and
especially if you saw his very
self-serious photo here on social media
you would believe this
were a an onion headline maybe not the
onion because that's lib but maybe a
babylon b headline or something but if
you're familiar with this guy's body of
work i guess
i guess you would have to conclude that
he's being serious here and so he's
saying
transgender rights
is where the fight for global
democracy is there's no avoiding it so
if he's being earnest
if he is being sincere and i i think the
jury is still out on that but let's just
say that he is
he's
making a statement that is completely
incoherent
democracy at least according to the old
definition that existed from
i don't know many centuries before
christ until five minutes ago
now all the way back to ancient athens
this but seventh century bc athens all
the way to the present democracy meant
popular government government where the
people get to rule
get to do what they want that was
democracy until then now what we're
saying is democracy hinges on a very
small radical minority
running roughshod over the desires of
the vast majority the vast majority of
people do not support
transgenderism they don't believe in
transgenderism they don't believe that a
man can secretly be a woman and they
certainly don't support drag shows
throughout our country and perverts
grooming kids the vast majority of
people oppose that not just right-wing
republicans but moderates and centrists
and liberals and democrats so what is he
talking how could he say it's the fight
for global democracy
again if he's being earnest and it's
hard for me to believe
that someone who ostensibly has a high
iq and lots of fancy degrees is could
really say something this stupid
although frankly i guess it's only an
ivy league professor who could say
something that's obviously stupid
he is saying that that that that is the
greatest cause of democracy overruling
the will of the majority that's the
greatest cause for democracy the ruling
class is really really pushing this
stuff frankly i think because most
people don't want it
i think the reason that the ruling class
is so focused on pushing transgenderism
is it's so obviously wrong it's so
contrary not only to
our
view of morality and our traditions and
our customs but nature itself it's so
obviously contrary to just basic biology
and the facts of reality that they think
if i can overcome nature if i can
overcome
reality and sex
i can overcome anything the revolution
will be total it will be in the words of
marks the ruthless criticism of all that
exists it will be in the words of the
serpent in the garden talking to eve it
will be
we
making ourselves gods
we shall be as god you shall be as gods
which whitaker chambers said was the
first political revolution it's the it's
the beginning of communism it started in
the garden of eden so i think that's why
they're pushing for it oh 90 some odd
percent of americans don't want to trans
the kids
all the more reason as to why we have to
because once we push past your ignorance
then we will destroy the false
consciousness and remake the world
however we want according to the sheer
tyranny of our will that's why
in san francisco right now the san
francisco mayor has decided to announce
a drag laureate
this year a drag laureate
a a laureate is someone who receives
public honors you think of the poet
laureate
tradition you'd have a a great writer
who is showing you something about
beauty and truth and human nature and
holding a mirror up to yourself and we
crown this person the poet laureate
because of their great contributions to
the specifically the life of letters but
the life of the arts and our own
understanding of ourselves now
now we put that laurel crown
on perverts jiggling for kids
that's i think the culture has fallen a
little bit uh the mayor london breed has
announced
san francisco's commitment to
inclusivity and the arts are the
foundation for who we are as a city drag
artists have helped pave the way for
lgbtq rights and representation across
our city and we must invest in programs
that continue their legacies we must we
must oh gosh how could we survive if we
don't spend taxpayer dollars promoting
drag queens
we have to create opportunities for the
next generation of drag performers to
thrive there it is again there's the
grooming there's the cultivating this
weirdness in kids
i want to thank the drag community man
everybody's got a community now huh
there is racial communities there there
are ethnic communities religious
communities and
transvestite communities okay the human
rights commission
and the public library for their work
and i look forward to crowning san
francisco's first ever drag laureate
this fall the drag laureate will receive
35 000 in an annual stipend the funds
will come from the san francisco public
library out of the two-year budget
proposal put forward by the mayor
so they're taking money
away from letting people read
they're taking money away from books
and education
and specifically allowing people who
don't have a ton of money to read
if you've got a ton of money you can go
buy the books if you don't have a ton of
money you go to the library they're
taking that money away and giving it
to a pervert
to jiggle and dance and pretend that
he's a woman in in a frankly offensive
caricature of what a man thinks a woman
is in his
weird sexual fantasies
that's what they're doing now
because our culture has become very very
dumb and very very radical and why is it
at the library why is the library seem
to be the epicenter of this drag queen
story hour very often takes place at the
public libraries well the first argument
was the library is a neutral place
it's a neutral place where everyone from
society can come and it can be little
kids and older people and it's neutral
and because of viewpoint neutrality and
value neutrality you have to let us do
our drag shows here it was a provocation
it was a test
and the real conservative said uh no we
don't
no
transvestitism was illegal in america in
many many cities including san francisco
for the 19th century into the 20th
century no we don't need to tolerate
this and we certainly don't need to
subsidize it he said yes you do this is
viewpoint neutrality you have to do it
and then what happens next
the squishes go along with it they say
we love viewpoint neutrality
and then what happens next it's not so
neutral anymore now the city is actually
taking money out of the library budget
to give to a drag performer how about
the preacher laureate how about the
laureate
how about the
conservative philosopher laureate no
there's no money for them only for the
drag queens because there is no
neutrality
because every state is going to
encourage some things and discourage
other things and it's going to have some
view of what is sacred and some view of
what is good
and right now we've convinced ourselves
the libs have pushed this campaign and
the squishes have fallen for it
that we're not allowed to say that good
things are good and we're not allowed to
say that bad things are bad
but we must say that bad things are good
and we must say that good things are bad
and we damn well better pay for it too
that's the the trap that conservatives
have fallen into now in our political
life what are we going to do about it
what are we going to do there's so much
confusion you got to go check out what
is a woman have you watched the movie at
the movie is really really terrific go
to what is a woman.com right now become
a member watch the film today we will be
right back with my absolute favorite
time of the week the mailbag do not go
anywhere the voicemail bag is sponsored
by puretalk go to puretalk.com select a
plan then enter promo code
knowles podcast canon
w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t
to save 50 off your first month
let's get to the voicemail back
hello michael
from time to time my mind wanders back
to that latter scene in austin powers
where dr evil
says to him we're not so different you
and i
isn't it ironic
that in the 90s all the things that you
stood for free love
parties drugs
are now considered to be
evil
and he says no we were innocent man
if we had known the consequences of our
sexual liberation we might have done
things differently but the spirit would
have remained the same
it's freedom baby yeah
and i always wonder if that
if that's really what the the
conservative backlash going on right now
is all about it's not about
the content so much as the procedure i
know that's not
what you like to think of but
it might be
that we are in fact the free love
movement
we just understand now what freedom
really means
so what do you think of this idea
this is a very good idea
i disagree with you a little bit but
this is such a good insight i do think
it has to do with not just the procedure
but the substance not just the form but
the actual content but the point you're
making generally is and that austin
powers and dr evil are making is really
really good
all desires
all of human desire
has as its true end
god ultimately and the good on the way
to god
good good thing is leading up to the
ultimate highest good who is god
our desires become disordered because
this is a fallen world
good desires
can can be perverted and go in the wrong
direction
and that's true of of all of us and it's
true in it manifests in different ways
for different people the solution to
this is not to deny your desire
the solution to this is not to
ignore it dismiss it try to even repress
it that's that's not the answer i know
that some people especially some
conservatives seem to think that's the
answer but it's not dante actually the
that good old italian poet
writing the divine comedy he gives a
better answer which is you've got to
when you want to be good when you want
to get closer to god when you want to
find salvation when you want to you have
to turn not just your actions and not
just your behaviors you have to turn
your desire
you have to turn your will
toward the good
and your and your will is is turned by
god's grace
and and ultimately it finds itself in
the love that moves the sun and the
other stars this idea of of desire
itself and so uh yes now the the
the
slight problem here for austin powers
and dr evil is that
you you can't just
you can't just substitute
lower
kind of perverted ideas of desire and
say okay well yeah the free love
movement of the 60s that wasn't great so
let's move it toward i don't know some
new type of freelance movement no the
issue the free love movement was just
wrong okay and it will find its fullest
expression in
in what we would call traditional values
finding a wife getting married
channeling your
your natural
sexual desires for your wife you see it
especially
dante even in heaven he's looking at his
love beatrice
and but beatrice is looking at god
and even there his desires have been so
transformed but there's still this he's
he's just looking at that immediate
object when really he's he's got to
look past the immediate object have the
immediate object channel his vision
toward god but it's very good this might
be the first time that austin powers and
dr evil and dante have ever been
discussed in the same paragraph next
question
hi michael i just wanted to thank you
first for helping me rediscover my faith
as a catholic i'm a lifelong catholic
who became a christmas and easter kind
of a catholic once i was done with high
school and i'm a 37 year old now i'm
married with two children and after only
baptizing both kids we are definitely
re-engaged recommitted and our lives are
much better already from it so thank you
very much for um helping re
relight the holy spirit within our
family
in that light i have no problem standing
up and defending um the catholic
church's stance on abortion it's been my
stance with or without religion
the one that i'm looking for your advice
about is how to handle having a
conversation with those people in our
lives that that are homosexual
and how would you how do you answer the
question about the catholic religion and
the catholic faith dealing with
homosexuality
i do believe that marriage is between a
man and a man and a woman but um the
reality is there are people
that i love that my wife loves that our
family loves
that
have chosen a lifestyle of homosexuality
and if that taught when that topic comes
up how can i confidently express my my
love for them still but stay true to my
faith in my religion
thank you and keep up the great work
really really great question something
that christians and jews and muslims and
people who have any traditional view of
sexual ethics
struggle with because you
the way that
conservatives christians whatever are
represented in the culture on this issue
is that we're hateful phobes we hate gay
people we want to throw them off of
rooftops and you know as you're
describing right now you know that is
not the case
so how can you
discuss this
the place that i would begin
is asking yourself why is it why is it
the case
that
every
cul virtually every culture in the
history of the world
has looked on
homosexuality
which is itself more complicated than
just two dudes doing it there's actually
much more complexity to the ideology of
homosexuality than just that
why is it that cultures have looked on
this as not quite right as uh it seems
like there's something wrong with this
uh it's a little
you have to begin i think with the
observation
that
certainly christianity makes but so does
judaism so does islam sort of
traditional cultures that homosexuality
is disordered that
that man is made for woman
and woman is made for man and man and
woman is compl are complementary and
that's the way it goes and that's how we
propagate the species and that's how the
world turns around
in many ways
that's not a hateful thing to say that's
just a fact if you talked to your normal
gay friend i have so many gay friends
i'm from new york i'm from l.a i went to
a very liberal
university where i think 97 of the
student body is gay and gets gay or
every year so
you know this is there's nothing hateful
coming from but
even your gay friends i think would
admit
this isn't the way
it's supposed to be this isn't the
normal thing right it's by definition
it's abnormal so if you begin from that
place
i think
the rest of your views on sexual ethics
will be much easier to discuss you say
okay if that's disordered then what
would be rightly ordered uh what what
are men and women supposed to do with
one another what obligations do i have
uh what does the natural law say about
this what does revealed religion say
about this and how has this worked
throughout history
this is not to say that you need to be
mean and cruel to your gay friends and
family members
divorce is wrong too
does does should you get divorced no
does this mean that you can never speak
to a divorced person you can never have
a divorced person over to dinner no
doesn't mean that either does it mean
that you need to disown your family that
gets divorced or that doesn't get
married in the church or that doesn't do
this that no it doesn't i don't think it
means any of that
but on the flip side
you also don't need to lie
about your beliefs or about things that
have been plainly understood for most of
human history until very recently you
don't need to do that either i don't i
don't think there's anything
compassionate about that i don't think
there's anything particularly respectful
about that
and
your i think your friends if they're
good strong sturdy normal people i think
they'll get that and you can have a
little bit of self self-effacement there
too
if a gay friend of yours says what you
don't think that this is perfectly the
most totally normal wonderful thing to
be celebrated with pride parades going
up and down the street all the time you
say i know i don't think so and look
there's some things about me that are a
little bit off-kilter too all right so
it's not i'm not saying it's a unique
you thing all right
nor is it the worst sin that you can
commit
i think a sin like fraud or betrayal of
your benefactor i think that would
probably be considerably worse but nor
do you have to say this is wonderful and
we need to have pride parades for it
you can you can have
you can you can speak about these issues
with complexity and nuance and calmness
too usually it's the people when they
get really really angry and red in the
face that is evidence that they don't
really know what they're talking about
and they're not really confident in
their beliefs all right next question
hey michael um so i have a question on
how to deal with
these discussions i have with people on
abortion and how to check the just
absolute
rage i feel in my heart when
i speak with them or try to have these
discussions
i have a person i grew up with at a
discussion today they were once again
comparing
a fetus to a tapeworm or a parasite
and i explained once again how this is a
completely illogical conclusion it's
stupid
and they go on you know with all these
arguments and their other friends about
how it's not really a baby and
it's okay to do it it's my choice and
all the talking points about how oh
people who are you know
poor and you know whatever having a
baby's gonna ruin their life and so i
point out that she has her daughter with
no father in the picture poor living at
home with her mother all the conditions
that are met so you justify abortions
for others and they said by you know
your own logic your daughter shouldn't
exist and the absolute insanity they go
off on it's just
it's really hard to comprehend because
apparently on the a-hole for making it
personal but then they don't understand
it when you don't make it personal it's
just abstract to them it's just a clump
of cells and then you make it personal
and you're the bad guy
like how do i deal with this and just
the anger i feel
when they start spouting off heretical
quotes from the bible and then saying
i'm the person who is against jesus
because i'm judging them for doing
things that are obviously evil
when they are trying to play god by
killing the unborn
thank you for all you do and look
forward to your advice thanks
great question totally dovetails off the
last question
you mentioned that your friend flies off
the handle i expect that to happen
you should not
one of the keys
to being persuasive in a debate
whether it's a debate with someone
you're talking to directly
and you're just trying to persuade them
or whether it's a public debate and
you're not really trying to persuade the
other guy you're trying to persuade the
audience one of the most effective tools
that you have is to remain calm
just remain calm even if they're
screaming at you and yelling at you when
you become really really angry you you
lose a lot of your ability to persuade
people
i don't think you're wrong to bring up a
personal example
i think that can be very powerful but
it's got to be done in a really calm way
so if you say you if you
had an abortion your daughter wouldn't
even be here or could you imagine of you
you know that that's going to put
someone much more on the defensive where
you say well no here's actually darling
here's the the problem with what you're
saying is
just by the logic of what you're saying
your daughter wouldn't exist and we all
know that nobody wants that people want
your daughter to exist so therefore
there's probably something just a little
bit gone wrong in your thoughts and your
friend might fly off the handle too but
i think she will be less likely to fly
off the handle people who are calm who
can just explain logically and
rationally why they believe what they
believe
are very persuasive all right let's get
to one written question at least though
i love my voice mailbag questions be
sure to submit them when you submit them
by the way
try to keep them relatively short you
know a minute or less is important here
or if you go on too long we can't use
them in the show all right from amanda
michael there's a lot of talk right now
about the gas prices and whether or not
it's biden's fault the prices are rising
can you lay out the reasons why we're in
this situation and why and if the fault
is with the current administration yes
it is largely joe biden's fault it's not
entirely joe biden's fault but it's
largely joe biden's fault it's joe
biden's fault well one the most
immediate driver of gas prices is the
war in ukraine the war in ukraine is
largely joe biden's fault zielenski the
president of ukraine said as much when
joe biden came into office there were
sanctions on a russian oil pipeline
called nordstream 2 the nordstrom 2
pipeline
was one of the keys for for vladimir
putin being able to feeling that he was
able to invade ukraine because he would
be able to avoid ukraine and continue to
ship his gas and and oil to europe
biden comes into office almost
immediately gets rid of those sanctions
he later on puts sanctions back on to
russia but zielinski said it was too
late if you guys had just had these
sanctions on earlier
zelinski believes the invasion of
ukraine wouldn't have happened so that i
put at joe biden's feet we're also not
producing oil pipelines now
biden has only shut down one oil
pipeline but to shut down one oil
pipeline is to shut down all of the new
oil pipelines because there are always
going to be
opposition campaigns from local groups
if you build an oil pipeline so so if
you're going to build it you need to
know the government's got your back if
the government is coming down and
shutting down one of them then you're
just not going to get new ones and then
biden also says no more new oil and gas
leases so
even just looking toward the future a
year out two years out three years out a
lot of these things being priced in
right now
the oil and gas industry knows okay well
we're not going to be able to build in
america under this administration so
that's his fault too there are always
other factors going on shutting down the
world that was a big factor in gas
prices going up
this this return to commerce and
business is creating a huge demand where
supply had been restricted that's going
to cause prices to go up it's not just
biden's fault that we shut down the
whole world but trump in many ways
acquiesced to it but it was the libs who
were driving that it was in our country
was the democrats who were really
driving that effort it was republicans
broadly who were trying to pull back a
little bit so is it all biden's fault
it's not all biden's fault but it is
broadly the fault of the libs i'm
michael knowles have a good weekend
we'll see on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boury supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022. hey everybody this is
andrew clavin host of the andrew clavin
show you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood but on the andrew clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me andrew
clavin